[Music]
good morning John it's Wednesday
February 14 I'm back in Montana for real
this time it's cold you see my breath
and it's snowing I've returned home to a
bit of a disaster my hard drive is
corrupt and I think I might have to go
get a new computer but today is
Valentine's Day so I feel kind of bad
taking my wife to Best Buy when I should
be taking her to I don't know
wherever you go on Valentine's Day I
should probably make some kind of plan
I've come down to the basement it's cold
out there
actually Valentine's Day is a pretty
exciting day for me because while in
high school i deciphered the true
meaning of Valentine's Day using a
little bit of back of the napkin
etymology etymology entomology etymology
etymology I worked out the true meaning
of Valentine's Day the word Valentine
comes from two roots the word Valen and
the word tine now most of us know what a
tine is it's one of these this fork has
four times time comes from the word zine
which is a german word that means
pinnacle or point
now the word Valen is less well-known
Babylon 5 aficionados will tell you that
Valen was the minbari not born of
minbari who bought the thousand-year
peace to the minbari people after the
shadow war thus we have Valen a semi god
of the minbari people and time traveler
and the word pinnacle or point my
assumption must be that Valen came to
earth in its past and brought us a
slightly different message and this
message had something to do with Valens
pinnacle thus the romantic connotation I
believe that Valen visited earth
sometime in the early 11th century and
that his visit was responsible for a
spike in the human population Valen
brought the message of his pinnacle
which increased the birth rate and gave
us a romantic holiday to celebrate happy
valence penis day is it weird that
that's the reason that I like
Valentine's Day anyway I probably sure
the Strawberry Hill challenge and here
it is I've just watched it for the first
time myself and well you'll see
[Music]
it's a brotherhood
oh it made me drool
little about Allah Oh
it's not to kind of film on the inside
of my mouth it it back here well I have
successfully completed the strawberry
yield challenge and it made me pretty
Burpee I don't know what I'm going to do
with the rest of it because I'm
definitely not going to drinking I have
a confession to make
it doesn't taste good but I keep wanting
to drink more did you know that this was
going to happen
did you know that I was gonna have one
glass and then I would have to drink the
entire bottle and that would make me
puke it tastes so bad I was there only
that much left this is what I have loved
oh the business farm Strawberry Hill
flavored citrus lime there's not any
more Strawberry Hill left eight
factories of totokira discussing the
political situation in Nepal he had fur
few to talk abou Alaska's new portal
situate Nepal in the protocol situation
in a bar he'd fetch it to third peer or
discussing the portal situation
opposition to his home owners who know
anymore
you